[Music]
you can literally go to a bar and when
they play single ladies someone's gonna
get up and they go through the entire
song gets higher you're sweating
dripping dripping in sweat
I'm sure whole night and I'm a
choreographer and image architect I
would describe my style as backyard
country fried chicken
hip hop lovin arm be soul dance it's
beyond the scope of being hip hop right
you know of course I'm a hip-hop
choreographer but it's about touching
people's souls
[Music]
I've work with the list of great talents
Beyonce jay-z zara larsson Pharrell
Williams any Rd Jennifer Lopez Britney
Spears Christina Aguilera and Cher
I think that's a good list for me if we
have a hit record the records not on a
hit unless you have a hit visual that
can go to it if I can give that within
my choreography then we have a smash for
me it's extremely important to always
include things that everyone can do I
won't dance to be inclusive
I want these moments to be inclusive so
when I was working with Beyonce on
single ladies there was a few moments
that connected with different people but
of course for starters you know is if
you liked it make sure to put a ring up
you know the ring and you can't do
anything else you can do this
[Music]
also choreographed lemon which was the
any Rd record featuring Rihanna every
piece of the song has its own identity
and the lemon itself as a signature
dance from it you know it's literally
taking your hands putting them together
and we're rocking right not and we
circle to the right most of my peers
grew up from the age of two in the dance
class but my first bit of training was
with music I grew up in a household
where music was something you play on
the daily and my family would get down
you know there was jamming we will have
a good time at the fish fry okay when I
hear music I connect to moments like
that so I started playing the alto
saxophone in fifth grade and in seventh
grade I started marching in a high
school band my discipline comes from my
years of margin you treat everyone with
respect so just as much as I was
learning to be a musician I was really
learning to be a better person and that
was the thing though in elementary
school I did take a clog in class I
[Music]
always forget about it and I was clogger
of the year actually I was really good
at it
[Music]
[Applause]
the things I'm doing now so much more
than choreography the dream has all the
paths it's nuts
even I'm so blown away by the growth
[Applause]
Pharrell just ran his first festival in
Virginia Beach his hometown and with
that happily hits entire set together
that had about 12 features in it we just
came from Sweden where I put a show
together
choreographed and helped with creative
on that working with zoar is really
special because she's a singer friends /
vocalist but she can actually dance
really well and she's a student to it
people don't get if you were the hardest
and they can't sing live the dance steps
don't mean anything
[Music]
sumaru jaquail is honestly and on there
he doesn't just only provide steps he
really just elevates the whole show I'm
so lucky you wanted to work with me he's
the best he's the best best best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's putting these moments at the right
time with the music which is also
important so when that part comes you
know exactly what you're about to do and
that's what I call magic it's the
marriage of music and that's where you
have these dance moments can last
forever they become bigger than you they
become bigger than the song at the
moment they become bigger than anything
you dreamed of they last literally
forever and the feeling of knowing that
people are doing something I created
it's beyond humbling to be ungrateful
is beyond being successful that's the
feeling it is for me because you have
touched these people old young rich poor
the choreography has fans in it is
bigger than all of those things which is
magical
you
[Music]